[Música]
hola bienvenidos a revista digital donde
abordamos los temas más importantes del
ciberespacio las redes sociales y los
medios de comunicación de américa latina
y el mundo
ante la situación de kobe 19 ahora
trabajamos de este caso una convención
poco convencional líderes delegados y
militantes del partido demócratas se
reunieron para nominar oficialmente a
joe biden y kamala harris como sus
candidatos para enfrentar a donald trump
ya michael pensa en las elecciones de
noviembre pero la pandemia de kobe 19
los obligó a hacerlo de una manera
virtual por primera vez en la historia
desde 1832 que desafíos tecnológicos y
de comunicaciones tuvieron que enfrentar
empezamos tras la denominación de bailén
y harris hubo un experimento político y
tecnológico sin precedentes la gran
convención de cuatro días se redujo a un
programa de dos horas diarias que se
emitió en horario estelar el equipo de
producción no la tuvo fácil el productor
ricky kirchner quien ha estado al frente
de espectáculos como el show de medio
tiempo del super bowl explicó el proceso
era una entrevista al portal deadline
dijo que en lugar de tener una sede
central para el evento el nuevo formato
los obligó a dividir su infraestructura
técnica en cinco locaciones ubicadas en
cuatro ciudades por ejemplo mientras una
sala de control estaba en milwaukee
wisconsin había otra en la ciudad de
delaware desde donde hablaron hayden y
harris paralelamente las presentadoras
de la convención entre quienes estaban
las actrices eva longoria y kerry
washington se encontraban en un estudio
en los ángeles nueva york fue otro de
los escenarios eso sin contar con que el
equipo tuvo que manejar unos 30
dispositivos que transmitieron en vivo
kirchner agregó que para ello sólo
tuvieron unos 10 días y era el proyecto
trabajaron unas 400 personas
según informó the washington post a las
decenas de oradores de las jornadas se
les enviaron kits de producción de vídeo
que incluían micrófonos equipos de
iluminación enrutadores avanzados para
que ellos mismos pudieran grabar y
transmitir sus propias tomas desde casa
la ex primera dama michelle obama fue
uno de los personajes que pregrado su
participación y aunque la mayoría fueron
discursos en vivo no se dio la
oportunidad de que hubiera interacción
con los votantes sin embargo para
recrear el usual ambiente de euforia de
los asistentes a estas convenciones el
equipo de producción realizó una
videollamada en vivo con decenas de
delegados de cada estado para que
pudieran aplaudir y reaccionar en tiempo
real a los pronunciamientos de los
personajes principales como si
estuvieran en el mismo recinto
en total fueron miles de vídeos
recolectados por los organizadores el
reto era que todo ello tuviera cabida en
tan solo dos horas de programación ya
que las cadenas de televisión se
comprometieron a emitir al menos una por
ello varios segmentos tuvieron
considerables recortes un típico
discurso duraría unos diez minutos pero
la mayoría de ellos fue reducido a más
de la mitad el famoso ronco en el que
los delegados de cada estado crean un
ambiente de suspenso para dar a conocer
los votos que recibió cada candidato
ahora se convirtió en un corto recorrido
virtual casi todos los voceros tuvieron
que enviar con anticipación un vídeo con
el resultado las presentaciones
musicales de famosos artistas como billy
y john legend se limitaron a una canción
y aunque una se agravaron y se
produjeron con anterioridad otras se
dieron en vivo
[Música]
ante este acontecimiento sin precedentes
los medios de comunicación estuvieron
vigilantes al resultado un artículo del
periódico the new york times' rescato
que durante el primer día la transmisión
se realizó sin problemas pero también
resaltó que la audiencia cayó en un 25%
en comparación con la última convención
demócrata de 2016 aunque reconoce que la
cifra no incluye a los espectadores de
internet mientras que el portal político
detalló que los asesores del presidente
de donald trump estudiaron el programa
televisivo de los demócratas y que éste
les sirvió como una especie de
instructivo sobre lo que funciona y lo
que no antes de que sea su turno de
subir al escenario los republicanos
también tendrán un programa de cuatro
días que culminará con la aceptación de
donald trump como el candidato de su
partido el mandatario manifestó su
intención de realizar su discurso desde
la casa blanca pero ha generado críticas
de quienes rechazan que use un edificio
federal para actos políticos
y para despedir cuando la convención es
virtual quién necesitas zapatos fue la
pregunta que hizo la senadora demócrata
amy klobuchar antes de su discurso a
través de su cuenta de twitter publicó
una fotografía ocultando sus pies
descalzos detrás del atril en redes
sociales también circuló la graciosa
reacción del ex aspirante a la
candidatura a la presidencia a bernie
sanders justo antes de su discurso en
vivo el momento se dio cuando su esposa
le dijo que se parase firme frente a la
cámara escuchen
no no
son
hasta aquí revista digital recuerde que
si quiere repetir este u otro episodio
de nuestro programa lo puede hacer a
través de nuestra página web www puntos
francia 24 punto com
[Música]